hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game from round five of this
year's us Chess Championship it is Hans
nean versus leevon arunan and we've seen
Fab's game against Andrew Tang Fab is
still in the lead but this game is also
very very important for the standings
which we will discuss after we check out
the game so uh once again we are
reminded that leevon Aran is I believe
physically incapable of playing a boring
game whenever he plays there's it's like
he plays Bug House chess you know pieces
are just all over the board and you have
to C at every move for your life so uh
let's check it out and also if there are
any fans of MMA what do you think about
the upcoming fight between Islam and
volkanovski with char Charles oliviera
stepping out do you do you like U who
whose chances do you like and also what
do you think of the first fight I'm very
much looking forward to it so very much
interested if you have any any thoughts
on that but okay uh getting back to the
game hun has the white pieces and he
opens with Pawn to E4 H leevon replies
with C5 he goes goes for the Sicilian
Defense Knight F3 E6 and now Pawn to C3
again the allop in variation we have
Pawn to D5 and now okay e cers on D5 is
the most um common move here but Hans
goes for the advance variation uh we
have D4 not allowing Hans to solidify
with D4 himself so D4 and now even Pawn
to D3 Bishop to D3 and captur on D4 are
uh a bit more played but D3 here by
hunts and now leevon just goes Knight to
E7 that he's very much interested in
putting his Knight on F5 and since hunts
will probably not be developing the
bishop to D3 or E2 he's going to go G3
so it's very unlikely that he will be
able to kick away the Knight with G4 all
in all Leon can even push H5 to stop G4
uh for for good so G3 and now there is a
game where Bishop to D7 was played but
here we have D captures and C3 and
already as of move six we have a
completely new game uh B captures and C3
we have Bishop to D 7 and now Bishop to
G2 hun is has F care of his Bishop puts
it on this beautiful long diagonal and
he is now ready to Castle we have Bishop
to B5 Leon H in and that D3 weakness and
pawn to C4 obviously a preparation by
Hans there's no way you'd allow this
hole to exist on D4 if you didn't think
this was good on the other hand you do
get some nice squares for your knight
the Knight is coming D4 in the future
might even end up on D6 so Bishop to C6
now ready to counter the bishop on G2
and now castles uh we have Knight to F5
of course the the square belongs to the
Knight we have Bishop to B2 and now
Bishop to E7 Queen to E2 and now Pawn to
H5 stopping any G4 ideas that hunts
might have and this is now officially a
monster knight uh Knight B to D2 the
Knight is coming to E4 and now Leon
really has to make a decision now I was
uh very much interested in this position
because it's basically the cross point
of this entire game and I've allowed as
usual the engine to Crunch the numbers
to around the depth 50 and the engine
says that you should play Bishop to A4
Knight to C6 as you freed up the square
for the Knight and go for Queen to A5 so
the game should be on the queen side
because uh uh if you're not going to
attack the king with something like H4
and G5 uh White will probably try to
grab hold of the queen so he does have
the strong Bishop he will put the Rooks
here and this is where the game should
be uh but like I said it is impossible
for leavon to play a boring game and
leavon plays goes for Pawn to H4 now
okay you could you could prepare with G5
Leon says Nope not not a problem and now
uh he asks Hans what what what to do
here now hun has a couple of options
here he went for Knight to E4 but
there's also a very interesting option
of executing G4 because now it's
possible however it's a very very long
and dangerous line which I believe uh
impossible to calculate for a human H3 G
captures on F5 H captures on G2 okay you
attack The Rook white moves The Rook now
e captures on F5 and now Pawn to D4 and
now look at this C captures on D4 Knight
captures on D4 and Bishop to C5 and if
you look at the black's Bishop pair if
you look at the Rook here the queen has
access to G5 this doesn't look like
something that should be okay for white
but the engine says that no this is
actually perfectly fine for White and
the reason okay you don't capture on F5
right away and allow Queen to G5 you
actually put the Knight on F3 take away
the G and H4 squares from the black
queen and now you are ready to capture
on F 5 and if um for example Bishop
captures on F3 uh you will play Queen
captures on F3 and now if Queen to H4
you will simply capture on G2 and uh you
know for an engine this is perfectly
fine nothing wrong with this uh but of
course we are humans so after Pawn to H4
hunts went for Knight to E4 and okay H
captures on G3 you could also prepare
you could go Bishop captures on e4 first
but um Leon goes for H captures and G3 F
captures now even giving The Rook the
semiopen f file and now Bishop captures
on e4 uh we have Queen captures on e4
now putting pressure on that B7 pawn and
just Knight to C6 Pawn to G4 now kicking
away the Knight Knight F to D4 and now
even Bishop captures on D4 with your
Pawn on E5 this doesn't uh look like
it's going to be you know a game where
the bishop will be relevant so he gives
it up Bishop captures we have C captures
and now Rook a to B1 so this is um what
leevon got out of the position for
attacking hans's King he will now have
to deal with some weakness is on the
queen side we have Queen to C7 and now
Pawn to G5 pushing on the king side we
have Pawn to G6 and now even Pawn to H4
and here again Leon has to figure out
how to play this but it's not easy as
you have so much pressure here uh on
that B7 Pawn uh also the the Rooks will
probably be doubled on the B file if the
Knight moves the if you push B6 the
Knight might also become a little bit
weak so you have a lot of problems here
to tackle so Leon figures that he has
the pawn D4 and he wants to play Bishop
to B4 Bishop to D2 and Bishop to E3 and
go for a kingside attack against hunts
and that's exactly what he does he plays
Bishop to B4 and now uh what do you
think about this position uh can you
capture on D4 it looks like maybe it
would be possible with something like
Knight captures on D4 the problem is
Bishop to C5 and uh you you're just
going to lose material and in the game
so here Hans finds a very nice plan
Knight to H2 now if he can land Knight
to F6 check your well this is good is
over so here leevon decides to Castle
and now Rook to B3 uh we have Bishop to
D2 by Leon so he will allow a Queens
side attack against his King but he will
also get a kingside attack against
hans's King Rook F to B1 and now Bishop
to E3 with check we have King to F1 and
now the problem is uh you can't really
stop the Rooks you you can no longer
play B6 because the Knight would just
hang and if you play something like
Queen captures on E5 then Rook captures
on B7 comes if Queen captures on e4 just
Bishop captures on e4 the Knight is
saying the Rooks are excellently placed
here on the uh seventh rank there's just
no good way to to handle this this is
dead lost for black so uh leavon had a
different idea he plays B6 and he
sacrifices the Knight on C6 stops Hunt's
attack on the B file and now he will try
to Checkmate hunt um with all of his
forces on the king side he does have the
great Bishop here the Rooks are coming
into the game on the H file uh this is
uh I mean absolutely thrilling so hunts
accepts the challenge Queen captures on
C6 Queen captures Bishop captures and
now Rook captures on H4 now the Knight
here is hanging so Knight to F3 and now
Rook to G4 uh now the other Rook is
coming to h8 and then to H1 and how can
Hans play this now if he can open up the
C file or rather play C5 and open up the
B file then it should be very good for
him the problem is he's too slow if he
plays C5 Rook to h8 and C captures on B6
it's a matter of Rook to H1 one with
check King to E2 and Rook to G2 will be
Checkmate so he has to figure out a way
out of this mating net so he plays Rook
to E1 of course he's already up material
uh and you don't want to be up too much
material if you can give a little back
just to survive the attack then that's
exactly what you should do uh leevon
does go for Rook to h8 and Hans is now
forced to give up The Rook Rook captures
on E3 d captures and King to E2 so now H
still has a bishop and Knight for a rook
uh but Rook to
H3 uh now of course if you if you
capture right away then Rook can capture
on G5 as the Knight is pinned and leevon
will create a pass G Pawn so Bishop to
E4 uh sorry uh here after Rook to H3
Bishop to E4 by hunt and now Rook to G2
with check King captures and now Rook
captures on G5 so Leon does get the pass
G Pawn King to F2 unpinning and now Rook
to G4 uh we have Rook to A3 uh here Hans
should also consider C5 C5 just opens up
the position and after captures Now The
Rook is immediately in the game but he
goes for a for a different line he plays
Rook to A3 now with excellent control
over the light squares with the bishop
uh he wants to control the A7 opponent
he wants to bring the Knight over to C6
and either Checkmate the the black king
or win a lot of material so how can
leavon counter this King B8 of course
first you have to defend the pawn Rook
to A6 and now Pawn to G5 he starts
pushing as uh well that's pretty much
the only thing he can do now and again
well C5 is an option H goes for the
immediate Knight to D4 now the idea is
of course you want deliver Knight to C6
check and start collecting so Rook to F4
with check King to E2 and now Rook to H2
with check we have King E3 Rook H3 check
King to D2 and Rook H2 check we have
King to C3 and here Believe It or Not uh
leevon played Rook captures on e4 and
the reason why he did this is because if
you start pushing with G4 then Knight to
C6 check King to C8 or doesn't really
matter what if you go here you get
checkmated none of the moves are really
okay for you King to C8 Knight captures
on A7 check King to d8 and Rook captures
on B6 uh you could capture on A2 okay
you can eliminate this Pawn Rook to B8
with check King to C7 and now Rook to B7
check let's say King to d8 and now you
will play Bishop to C6 and you are
checkmating black there's no way out of
this black either has to give up more
material or if he starts pushing then
you get Knight to B5 and now you have
control over these two squares that's
pretty much it pawn to G2 Rook to B8
with check only move King E7 and Rook to
E8 will be Checkmate so the problem for
one is that he he's just not in time to
start pushing the G Pawn so he plays
Rook captures on e4 it's the only way to
continue uh D captures and now Pawn to
G4 maybe The Rook can handle the Knight
defending the pawn but there's also
another piece defending against the pass
pawn and that is the white king So King
to D3 and now again if you start pushing
King to D3 already sort that Knight to
E2 and once you play G2 there's King to
E3 and once you prepare the queen with
Rook to H1 King to F2 stops the pawn and
G1 is controlled twice by the king and
by the Knight so after King to D3 Rook
to F2 was played H and now comes King to
E3 with have Rook to F1 King to E2 Rook
to F4 going after the E4 pawn and now if
you don't want to repeat the position
you have to try something else Hans
plays Rook to A3 uh Rook captures an E4
check King to D3 and now Rook to e or
Rook back to E1 of course you cannot
capture on E5 you run into a fork with
Knight to C6 check so very unfortunate
for for leavon uh he goes back Rook to
E1 and now we have Knight to E2 and this
now uh covers the G3 square but also
covers the queening square that is the
G1 Square so time for leavon to activate
the king king B7 uh King to D2 now
attacks The Rook Rook to A1 and now
Knight to C1 trying to box in the the
black Rook so if you allow it The Rook
will be captured uh Rook to B1 trying to
escape and now not even King to C2
because then you allow Rook to B4 uh
Rook to G3 going after Leon's only
counterplay it is a much more precise
Rook B2 check King to C3 Rook to F2 and
now Rook captures on G4 with have Pawn
to A5 now comes Pawn to A4 stopping any
advancement black might have on the
queen side Rook to F1 attacking the
Knight Knight to D3 we have Rook to A1
going after the pawn now comes Rook to F
four trading the a pawn for the F7 Pawn
so Rook captures on A4 Rook Capt sorry
first um one check was given Rook to A3
with check uh King to D4 and now Rook
captures on A4 Rook captures on F7 with
check King to C8 and now Knight to F4
going after the E6 Pawn B5 it's uh I
mean you have to play this uh create two
connected pass pawns Knight captures on
E6 Rook captures on C4 with check and
King to D5 so now pun does have the two
sorry Leon does have the two connected
pass pawns but Hans has a king Knight
and rook in front of levon's King and
also the past E Pawn is ready to start
marching forward to pawn to A4 and of
course Rook to A7 just putting the Rook
behind the pass Pawn uh Rook to C1 and
now comes Knight to D4 and believe it or
not it was in this position on move 63
that leevon Aran resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
you cannot Advance the pawns you cannot
push this Pawn you cannot push this Pawn
uh it's uh you know Point pointless to
continue this and one way you could
continue as I know you guys like it when
I show how the game might end Rook to D1
is just to advance the E6 pawn and now
if King to d8 you can even play King to
E5 uh and now uh okay you can't go Rook
to E1 check because King D6 and then the
black king just gets checkmated so you
have to play something like A3 but white
does not have to take the pawn of course
white will go for checkmate Knight C6
check King to C8 you will play Pawn to
E7 check and okay a few more checks Rook
E1 check King to D6 Rook to D1 check
King to C5 and after Rook to C1 check
King to B6 now threatening Checkmate you
will have to take the Knight captures
captures and now after King to B8 of
course uh a few more moves and that's it
you go here or you go here doesn't
really matter you will get checkmated we
don't even need a queen a rook will
suffice for the job uh but after Knight
to D4 leevon said all right I've had
enough uh you win this game so uh yeah
like I said it can all be uh traced back
to that very very cool position where uh
Leon decided to execute H4 I mean this
is only move 13 where you could decide
okay the the center isn't really moving
white will not be playing D4 anytime
soon we have a very sufficient control
uh White will not be playing on the king
side as White Castle King side and we
control the G4 Square so uh maybe it's
time to you know uh continue in in a
nice calm fashion uh and get the Knight
into the game maybe Castle Queen side uh
but no leavon is not that kind of a
player he played Pawn to H4 and that's
why we got this incredibly incredible
game that was played uh to a very high
standard by by both of them but in the
end hunt emerged Victorious uh so that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it here
are the standing or first let me just
tell you the results from the final from
the fifth round so Hans defeated leevon
uh SCH drew his game against Samuel
seian Ray Robson defeated Jeffrey Shong
uh then we have ler Dominguez Perez
defeated Samuel shankland Andrew Tang
lost to Fabiano corana it's the previous
video that I made made if you haven't
seen it brilliant brilliant setup
against the London system do check it
out and the Wesley so defeated ABI Manu
Mishra so these are the standings after
five runs so Fabiano still in the lead
with four out of five HTS trailing uh by
half a point in second place clear clear
second place with three and a half out
of five then with three points Dominguez
Perez and Wesley so with two and a half
points we have Sam Shanklin Samuel seian
and abanu Mishra two points out of five
Leon Aran Ray Robson and Dario SCH and
with one and a half points Jeffrey Shong
and Andrew Tang so there you have it
those are the standings we'll see what
happens uh if you guys are interested
who faces who in round six so Karana
will be facing seian Shanklin will be
facing SCH Mish abanu will be facing
Dominguez Perez leevon will be facing
Wesley so so we have really an
incredible top level game Jeffrey Shong
will be facing H nean uh and Andrew Tang
will be facing Ray Robson uh so there we
have it a little bit about the the
tournament as well hope you enjoyed that
I would like to thank Mr hoody Guy Peter
marinov an anonymous person Roger Stone
and no need to mention me in the video
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions but mostly
covering the US CHS Championship until
it finishes uh so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and if you are not receiving
notifications from the channel when I
upload a video as some of you have
mentioned I will put a first link in the
descript descrition below it's a link to
my telegram Channel where you will be uh
informed when the video is released
right away so do join if you if you find
that useful uh see you soon